well shamima begum is notorious as the
isis bride banned from returning to
britain began with just 15 when she and
two other east london school girls
traveled to syria to join the terrorists
in 2015 her attempts to come home have
sparked a global furore to some she's a
victim a child exploited by terrorists
to others she's a terrorist herself and
a threat to national security the uk
stripper of citizenship in 2019 arguing
her bangladeshi heritage means she's not
stateless in practice now the country
will let her in and begin now age 23 is
stuck in a syrian detention camp where
most british people think she should
stay but this week another twist she may
be smuggled into syria by canadian spy
with canada now pledging to investigate
is it time to give begum another hearing
perhaps even mercy well joining me now
is filmmaker and journalist andrew drury
he's met and interviewed swimming with
bagan on numerous occasions i think
she's playing the victim and mars and
beg an author and former guantanamo bay
detainee he thinks we should let him
back into the country welcome to both of
you uh andrew drury let me ask you
you've met her a number of times
including just five weeks ago i think
you had contact with her
so you've got to know pretty well i have
yeah what is your belief about the kind
of person we're talking about and the
kind of potential threat she may present
to this country if she did come back
she's a manipulator when i first met her
i was filming a documentary and did on a
day off and at that point she was
playing sorry i'm sorry for britain and
my last meeting she started to become a
victim she believes that she was
trafficked she wasn't trafficked she
says she was but she's told me a whole
story so she's now playing this part as
a victim
funnily enough you've got a guy from who
was in guantanamo bay she asked me if i
could bring a book out there for her um
go go tanama bay diaries um about
somebody was there in their 14 years
without trial because that's how she's
seeing herself now a victim right he's
no victim mowers in beg here's my
problem with this whole case with
shamima beg i've followed it for a
number of years i just can't get past
the fact that she spent years there
fathering uh mothering a number of kids
by a jihadi father who was fighting with
isis
she knew what they were doing she saw
what they were doing
and she just stayed and was in my view a
willing accomplice to this whole
isis phenomenon over there why should we
show her any mercy why should we have
any pity for someone who was so
merciless and pitiless herself
oh pierce i don't think it's a question
of mercy at all i think really it's a
question of the law and a question of
the application of it across the board
so for example there are several people
who were part of isis who've returned to
the uk some are in prison some are out
some are on uh terrorism prevention and
uh investigative measures i.e uh akin to
house arrest so there's different
there's different ways
that that britain knows how to and can
and has dealt with this uh the real
issue is is shamima being targeted
because the nationality was revoked was
it a political statement or was it one
that was based on law and i think it's
the former and not the latter
the role of the intelligence services in
all of this also cannot be underplayed
and if if you'll allow me i think you
you may remember you came to belmosh in
2014
to visit andy coulson i was in belmont
at the time and i was being prosecuted
for sending a generator to syria now my
case fell apart uh the police delighted
to get declared me innocent and i was
found not guilty but i was held with an
individual who um
told me a fascinating story he was a
young man from london who said that he'd
been recruited by mi5 to go and spy for
them against isis
and they'd given him huge amounts of
money to do so
uh mi5 and the police eventually thought
that he's a he's playing
a double game he's a double agent so
they arrested him and tried to prosecute
him for terrorism
and his case was the first case in
british legal history to have been
almost entirely heard in secret because
of the role of mi5 in his case it was it
was it was completely bizarre okay
if i can i want to focus more on
something
so the relevance to this case pierce is
this is that he was then taken put on a
deportation order in the uk and his
nationality was revoked in the uk and
then he was deported so that uh the
details of his case would never become
come to life so in the same way in shame
begins case um the role of the
intelligence service it's impossible
that the security services that the
police didn't know that an m that a an
agent for csisis the canadian
intelligence services was facilitating
the travel of her and other british
individuals
if that is what's happened i mean there
are so many unanswered questions here
what is what is not unanswered andrew
drury is is we know that she willingly
was there with these isis killers as
they were committing utter atrocities
and again i keep coming back in my head
i was like i don't know why we should
let her back in this country
first he got onto the agent side of it
she wasn't aware she told me how she got
there she wasn't aware of any agent she
had some cut the syrians um guided her
over into turkey she says a girl called
shamina was the girl that arranged it
she wasn't um
she it took her only six months she made
her own decision she wasn't watching
videos or she wasn't had some preacher
told her or she you know this was her
choice she decided you think she's still
dangerous yeah she wants to be a
somebody like now she sees herself as a
celebrity she enjoys all you know all
this that she's getting from us the
press the media even she'll be watching
this tonight she'll hear you know should
this interview go she loves what she
wanted she would have gone anyway she
wanted to be somebody being part of isis
she thought she was somebody now she's
in the camp she likes being somebody
again she's not she's not a victim i
don't i don't think she has any right to
come back to this country no moral right
i don't think she has a legal right and
i think the most british public agree
with me about this uh i've got to leave
it there andrew jury thank you very much
indeed mozambique thank you as always
your insightful contribution i
appreciate it